hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I I'm just checking in on ya I'm just
checking in on you seeing how your weeks
going that's all I'm doing here just
running my [ __ ] freckled Yap for
another 30 minutes of my goddamn life
and you know what you're going to sit
there iris let's do it unless you don't
want to then you can always hit stop you
can find another website you know watch
some porn at work
pretend you're working put your right or
left hand and your slacks your action
slacks you know rub one out so people
later you got to lay up the glazed
doughnuts ah ah that early in Jesus
Christ you go with the jizz joke that
[ __ ] early and it does not show a lot
of promise that was in under a minute
the first kiss joke you know what I mean
that's like when you watch one you know
quickest knockout you know and you're
looking at the other guy like why the
[ __ ] did you even show up
you know I could have done that I could
have gone in there with no [ __ ]
training whatsoever what so and I could
have got my [ __ ] ass knocked out in
less than a minute you know although I
wouldn't have the balls to then go try
to figure out what I did wrong and then
come back to potentially have it again
and that's what separates the audience
member from the professional fighter
that gets knocked out in a minute
you know whenever you see that there's
always that guy do it really you could
have gotten top physical condition you
tub of [ __ ] [ __ ] sittin there eat
fried dough in a boxing match I didn't
know they'd sell it they said II know
they sold that [ __ ] at a boxing match
you fat [ __ ] what do you think wait
where'd you find that huh she's like
some [ __ ] food whale you know like
when the when the degenerate gamblers
show up and they get flown in to get
this giant suite to let go [ __ ] Bali
so you know they roll out the red carpet
[ __ ] you already paid for it they're
looking for you to buy another jet you
know they probably do that with people
who are really fat you know what I mean
when they show up hey just to let you
know fat
Frank's showing up and he's going to the
boxing match sure let's bring in some
extra chefs and add to the menu to give
the [ __ ] of no one else eats fried dough
this guy will eat enough fried dough to
justify it you know No all right
whatever you got it just joke I'm making
fun of fat people this isn't good
oh this is what you probably thinking
cheese bill your energy is a little bit
high for a Thursday afternoon oh maybe
you're not thinking that maybe I'm
saying you thinking that and I'm getting
in your [ __ ] head right the way
advertisers feel that they do that they
show one every five seconds rather than
just getting annoyed on in the internet
you're going to be like oh you know what
I think I will [ __ ] book I never
watch them which is really hypocritical
because I have AI of advertising on this
broadcast but you guys also have the
option just fast-forwarding it yeah just
fill up Amy that's what I like about
YouTube it's like you must watch this so
what I always do is I hit [ __ ] mute
and then I just scroll down just and I
read some of the comments and I just
jest at the top of the screen I could
see that big sliding across and then I
know it's [ __ ] you know why there's
about twenty years ago I was in a bar
and this woman was an advertising that I
meant and she kept telling me that it
works i'ma go it doesn't work sometimes
it annoys me and it makes you smell but
it's in there it works it totally works
she just kept saying no it works it's
just like and I was so young and dumb
it's like Bill this is the industry
she's in okay
why don't you just go tell somebody that
their religion is wrong you know of
course she's going to defend it
what's she going to do say yeah it
doesn't work and that she's going to go
to work in the morning but I was younger
you know full head of [ __ ] orange red
hair doing my best talking to the ladies
down on Newbury Street right
what do you stay there [ __ ] old black
dress their [ __ ] goth looking chick
that's all I remember of them back then
all those [ __ ] goth looking chicks
just [ __ ] walking around down on
Newbury Street did Doc Martin it all
that [ __ ] you go over two days if you
can is that was the meat market right
that was the chicks that went to the gym
unlike the goth ones that were on
Newbury Street they were all [ __ ] sad
you know taking the weight of the world
on their shoulders those [ __ ] and days
you can and didn't give a [ __ ] they
still don't give a [ __ ] you know what I
mean [ __ ] starfish tattooed above the
butt crack just walk it around and get
my [ __ ] I walk in there with my [ __ ]
waist length leather jacket my driving
gloves little did they know I stepped
out of an 83 Ford [ __ ] raised yeah
two-wheel drive the extra log bed vinyl
seats five-speed had a radio but
somebody smashed the window and took it
oh yeah ladies that's what your [ __ ]
your dream boat is arrived
Seinfeld like white sneakers you know
the high tops coming in you know dad
jeans that were considered cool back
then maybe it's flood shirt that said if
spirit or whatever the [ __ ] is spirit
not a bad [ __ ] image but it's a true
one I'll tell you what isn't a bad image
did you guys watch well I guess it is if
you're Dallas Stars fan did you guys
watch games the st. Louis Blues all meet
me in state Louie Louie see us a Western
Conference final don't tell me the Blues
are choking this is a different year
[ __ ] st. Louis Blues repeat this the
st. Louis Blues had a game seven in
somebody else's building and not only
did they win they gave him the old right
there Fred right there
five to one they were up five to nothing
at one point they were leading the
series three to two and they got that
[ __ ] they got their lunch served to
him they got their hat pant or whatever
you want to say in Game six
all right couldn't close them out and
then they were going down to Dallas and
I'll give a [ __ ] how big of a st. Louis
Blues fan you are you know goddamn well
you've been slapped in your in your your
[ __ ] sports fan face too many times
by the st. Louis Blues is dick okay they
do it to every [ __ ] year they get you
excited
you go oh my god here we go the playoffs
right in the face and then it's [ __ ]
over you know it right
you probably thinking that they were
going to [ __ ] blow it against the
Blackhawks and holy [ __ ] they came back
and they said right so now they get
another game seven against the Dallas
Stars and as much as you will stay in
you're a fan and you believe and you got
your little trinkets and you sitting in
your lucky chair in the back of your
head you know it you're going into the
Blues they're going to [ __ ] blow this
and Jesus Christ did they give you guys
an easy ride huh three to nothing after
one then four to nothing and I know
goddamn well when you're rooting for a
perennial [ __ ] loser right that
always breaks your heart you need five
goals you need five goals to feel
comfortable you know I remember all of
this [ __ ] back before we started winning
every champion bet championship that
exact yeah [ __ ] Red Sox I was
comfortable with like a 12 13 run lead
but not if we were playing the Yankees
and it was only the eighth inning prior
to 2004 I was not comfortable with it so
what a [ __ ] they just they just went
down they just [ __ ] everything they
caught the net [ __ ] went in even what
Tarasenko is that where does goal ever
trying to pass it he's almost parallel
with the net and it did like the magic
bullet JFK thing and somehow went into
the [ __ ] back of the net and they
took that away and I was like out God
and the [ __ ] stars are flying up and
down the ice that dogs at night Dallas
right there [ __ ] sorry it's flying all
over the [ __ ] ice and I'm like watch
this
here come the stars they're gonna get
the [ __ ] equalizer right and then
it's going to change the whole [ __ ]
shape of the game and then the [ __ ]
blue sky give me all right there Fred
two more [ __ ] types if I remember
correctly and then all sudden was
[ __ ] three to nothing and then
forward enough and then five to nothing
and then the [ __ ] stars scored a goal
and I said ah [ __ ] Dhoni don't even tell
me but then I just got to doing the math
going like all right there's ten minutes
left they need four goals they'd have to
scroll one every two and a half [ __ ]
minutes
and then like two and a half minutes
went by and then it's like I'm not doing
the math this is for this game it's
[ __ ] over and I said the game was
over only was five to nothing but even
though I said that I wouldn't have left
like most of the [ __ ] douchebags fans
there were along the boards did you see
how many [ __ ] fans left
they're not even fans those are all the
hookup [ __ ] that just went out with
some VIP place afterwards they really
made they always make the fans of the
team look bad because I know the upper
deck was still packed and when the Stars
lost five to one
everybody was left with standing on
their feet applauding them I'm just
letting Stars fans know I'm not judging
your fan base by those [ __ ] the
hook-up constant want to know the people
at the radio station the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that are then going to go to a steak
house and try to bang some nine year old
guy and [ __ ] get his ATM PIN number
I'm not judging you guys by then you
know when the game's over they should
pan up to the upper deck and see all the
[ __ ] die hards but sad to see the
stars go obviously if they got some net
mind of problems then Sagan didn't play
the whole [ __ ] he didn't play the
whole playoffs and I'll say right now
that's why the Bruins that's why the
Bruins got rid of them could make myself
feel better that's why we got rid of we
know we know yeah he'll get you 3040
goals during the regular season where is
he in the playoffs huh what happened to
him what happened to him did he sprained
one of his abs dancing with his shirt
off and some [ __ ] one of those coyote
ugly bars
it's what the [ __ ] he was doing he was
playing with us I didn't know that's
true that's what the rumor was all right
here we go
let me see here Tyler Seguin injury what
happened to him well then I'm never
going to say he's got a lower body in
the waist area injury injured stars
Tyler Seguin makes progress but not
enough a lower body injury they always
say that so he's a lower body body
injury that means you [ __ ] up your
shoulder you know because if they say
what it is these [ __ ] animals will
actually have to go after it so yeah
Tyler Seguin was the [ __ ] no-show
say right now Mach Messier he would have
got his ass out on the ice oh yeah you
know that I was saying you know he's
just a little [ __ ] underwear model of
[ __ ] with you
am I kidding I know what time I [ __ ]
blocked a wrist shot and pick up hockey
and I was limping for like [ __ ] ten
days all right that's the level of [ __ ]
I am so I'm just [ __ ] around Dallas
to our fans here but congratulations to
the blues tonight predators San Jose
Shea Game seven and I don't know who I
want to win like I love the Predators
because I don't know I just like they're
[ __ ] you knees and squish you
whatever get the south into [ __ ]
hockey and it's something about this -
something funny about the Sharks choking
every year and I don't know why but I
just do not respect San Jose as a sports
town I just can't do it
you know I don't respect it because none
of you have the balls to live downtown
you all live outside you know when
you're safe little how little houses
done too high they're all made out of
ticky tack and we're afraid to go
downtown oh my god is that a trolley you
have a [ __ ] trolley going through the
center of town how much more quaint do
they have to make it I'm just [ __ ]
with you downtown San Jose is no joke in
fact I remember the comedy club somebody
got shot and killed was [ __ ]
hilarious and then the comedians like I
forget who the [ __ ] it was that week but
they took the picture and they had like
the whole improv like marquee out front
with the name of million um of the
comedian you know probably had some
wacky photo then then they just have a
body with like a you know goddamn
blanket over it so I understand that but
then I was thinking we'll be cool if the
Sharks and the Blues play each other
then somebody will finally sort of break
their curse to get to the finals I don't
know if the Sharks have ever made a
final and I don't know if the Blues I
don't can't remember the last time the
Blues did the last one I remember was
they was against
[ __ ] Boston Bruins and I wasn't going
to look really old enough to even have
watched that they might have done it
sometime in the 90s and 2000 but I was
doing so much stand-up I missed a lot of
hockey Becket's let's look this up st.
Louis Blues last finals yeah I don't
think they've been in it forever last
Finals appearances all right
the st. Louis Blues financial problems
in playoff Street 1970 1987 let's see
list of Blues seasons I don't need this
[ __ ] too much here Stanley Cup champions
that's a big goose egg conference
champion I think that's a goose egg to
know it isn't because they've been to
the finals conference champion Stanley
Cup champion they want to have it come
on you know what tell me just text me
this because I don't want to [ __ ]
this is year by [ __ ] year somebody
actually looked at this [ __ ] watching
aren't you looking at all this isn't
what the [ __ ] I wanted to look at season
was shortened due to strike in 94 95 two
stones uh you know I thought I had to
ask the question pretty [ __ ] clearly
you know st. Louis Blues Blues history
do I have to hit pause dude so until got
a smack a [ __ ] remember that from
[ __ ] Stanley Cup Finals record here
we go
st. Louis Blues Stanley Cup well you
know what go [ __ ] yourself [ __ ] you
internet every once in a while
I thought you had all the answers at
least somebody making an attempt to give
me one and how it works
so whatever I think I think I almost
want the Sharks to win tonight because I
don't know it's done I did with the
[ __ ] crazy beard you know it could be
fun to watch back and forth their blues
predators you know I don't know that's
almost like a Subway Series of five
southern cities st. Louis is a southern
city they try to act like they're
[ __ ] and from the Midwest yeah go
and talk to some people Jesus Christ
everybody there's got overall it's
[ __ ] unbelievable you know they got a
Budweiser right in that little [ __ ]
pocket
I'm kidding they go alright um oh by the
way tomorrow Lulu Lulu like Jim is done
tomorrow my gym is done tomorrow and Oh
freckles it's going to turn into Joe
[ __ ] weird no I'm going to work it my
[ __ ] ass in shape here because I am
in writers from shape right now
and I'm dealing with which is almost
gone I've been taking my
anti-inflammatory drugs and doing all
these [ __ ] stretches I didn't even
have to go to a chiropractor but maybe
I'll go I don't me it keeps telling me
to go so maybe I'll go but anyways I got
my [ __ ] I got my [ __ ] atomic holds
you know I got my my pegboard
I got a speed bag for Nia and then I got
a I got a bench I got a [ __ ] squad
rack
I got a pull-up bar I get a dip thing
and I also got my climbing rope so there
we go and all I got to do is take my dog
for a walk around the block for my
cardio nothing [ __ ] crazy not beating
up the knees or the feet you know eat a
salad every day like some [ __ ] yoga
instructor right lay off the booze that
ain't happenin
lay off the cigars that might happen I
have I'm smoking too in June and then I
think I'm done until October and if I do
that then I'll only have smoked ten for
the year and I even think that's too
many I just think it's too many I'd like
to be I'd like to smoke six a year this
is what I'm going to do next year all
right it's going to be I'm smoking New
Year's Day at the Rose Bowl I'm going to
smoke at the Super Bowl
then I'm not smoking until my birthday
in June and then I'm going to smoke
see here I go to a big college football
game I'm going to smoke then and then
that day I smoked for a year I [ __ ]
enjoy the [ __ ] out of it but I don't
blow out my jaw my tongue on my throat
or in that stuff I don't need that I
don't need that my [ __ ] like so
speaking of which you should probably
ask yourselves at this point so bill
what is the big college football game
you're going through this year so you're
right now we go sideways down a
Janesville Florida Gators taking on the
LSU Tigers within brand new head coach
will it [ __ ] welcome whoever the [ __ ]
he is I don't know ia's I'm beyond
excited to go down there to the swamp
I actually really like love both those
programs I mean I like the Florida
Gators way back I would totally suck
that orange helmet with the blue shirt
which is [ __ ] was the [ __ ]
somewhere along the line moving out to
Los Angeles college football coming on
so early and I had the time to watch it
stead of driving to gigs on Saturday I
got into LSU with the Mad Hatter as
coach and I don't know that's going to
be a tough one I don't know who the root
fool in that one I
I want to go LSU but I don't to be that
[ __ ] that goes to somebody Stadium and
[ __ ] roots against the home team I
mean it's not like I'm that [ __ ]
emotionally invested to be a douche bag
and I'm just going to go there and just
hope it's a good game anyway so I don't
know where I'm going to be performing
but somewhere in that area that area and
[Music]
really [ __ ] looking forward to that
so I know so two more cigars in tune and
then I'm going to be done for a while
allegedly oh yeah right there like
you're going to go to [ __ ] Europe
then you just have any Cuban cigar you
want you're not going to go when it's
smoke one let's come over there for 10
days and just smoke one that's okay
right
alright let's let's read a little bit of
advertising here sorry
oh it's our old friends here Club W
convenience club W do you have any oil I
want I want your oil come only delivers
wine straight to your door personalized
we send you wine that is personalized to
your palate slash
through our palette quiz our
recommendations become an even more
person become even more personalized
with every bottle you rate we work with
top winemakers and growers from around
the world world world world directly to
make all of our wine high quality and
value our 13 dollar bottle would
normally retail for 20 bucks that
probably doesn't sound like a lot of big
difference until you do the percentage
you know what I mean I mean five times
20 to 100 dollars five times 13 is 65 no
risk you choose the type and quality of
bottles with no membership fee or
cancellation fee and 100% satisfaction
guarantee
creative we partner with local artists
to develop wine labels that are unique
works of art right now at Club W sedan
broaden our sim it's offering listeners
$20 off your first order when you go to
clump get viacom / / and it gets even
bad I know you all hate paying for
shipping so Club W Daniel s remote and
chip will actually pay for your shipping
on orders of four bottles or more so
take something off your to-do list just
go to club Debbie dot-com / / to get $20
off your first order right now that's
Club Debbie dot-com / / alright tip are
you hiring are you are you I just went
what to Satan's Breakfast Club do you
know why I'm here
do you are you hiring are you do you
know where to post your job to find the
best candidate will do you Johnny Oduya
posting your job in one place isn't
enough to find quality candidates if you
want to find the perfect hire you need
to post your jobs on all the top job
sites and now you can with ship recruit
up calm you can post your jobs to 100
plus job sites including social media
networks like Facebook and Twitter all
with only one single click find
candidates in any city for any industry
nationwide just post once and watch all
of your qualified candidates roll
right to Daddy come to daddy baby into
zip recruit it's easy to use interface
no juggling emails or calls to your
office no pain in the ass quickly screen
candidates rate them and hire the right
persons fast find out today why zip
recruit has been used by over 800,000
businesses and right now listeners can
try zip recruiter for free by going to
zip recruited comm / / that dip
recruited comm / / one more time try it
for free go to zip recruiter comm / /
hey and if you're looking for a job I
bet there's a way to upload your resume
to zip recruiter
all right track our tracker when the
hell's the top of this copy alright my
Chas smartphone technology has made
everything wicked smack but losing stuff
still makes people feel really stupid no
tracker makes losing things a thing of
the past well gee bill how the [ __ ] does
it work well I'll tell you
trackers are coin-sized device that
locates misplaced keys wallets bags
computers anything in seconds
just put tracker on a scarecrow and
you're like oh there's where I put it
wait they don't move just put tracker
onto your smartphone attach it to
anything and find its precise location
with the tap of a button it's that easy
lose your phone press the button on
tracker and your phone rings even when
it's on silent with over 1.5 million
devices tracker has the largest crowd
GPS network in the world world world
world so you your lost item shows up on
a map even if it's miles away never lose
anything again with tracker listeners to
this show get a special discount of 30%
off your entire order go to the tracker
dot-com and enter promo code bir the
hardest thing you'll ever have to do is
find their website that's north go to
tracker calm right now and enter the
promo code bar for 30% off your entire
order again that's tracker comm promo
code bar you can't tell me some stalkers
not going to throw that in the book bag
of some [ __ ] dude you know [ __ ]
try and Buck them doing some [ __ ] out of
score big every
money you're paying too much for your
paying too much for tickets between the
markups and last-minute convenience
changes even print-at-home fees are you
kidding me or what use end up you end
use
you end up paying courtside prices for
nosebleed seats score big is here to
change that did you know that 40% of all
live event tickets go unsold and did you
know that there's a place to get these
seats at huge savings it's called score
big score big works directly with your
favorite teams and artists to get their
unsold seats at unpublished prices only
with score big can you name a ticket
price and be guaranteed to pay below
box-office up to 60% off here's what you
do one go to score big calm or download
the new score big app for your iPhone
and find the event in seats you want to
make an offer with score bigs name and
ticket price feature free get an instant
answer and save up to 60% on your
tickets for take your dick out say I'll
go to the game no never any fees and
shipping is always free you can count or
on unbeatable prices and great seats and
when you're in great seats you actually
enjoy the game or show all the more next
time you go see any game or show go to
score big first and see how much you can
save for the easiest way to save on
tickets download the new score big app
for your iPhone and to promo code bar at
the checkout and you'll save an extra
$20 off your first ticket purchase no
iPhone no problem get $20 off online to
its score big calm that score big calm
promo code bar score big calm promo code
bar all right let's talk attempted
suicides here shall we
yesterday a man in a green Celtics
sweatshirt climbed up the KTLA TV tower
and interestingly enough we're writing
ethics for family not too far away so we
saw the helicopters but couldn't see the
guy and so out here you know in LA they
show everything live on the news except
now when they think somebody's going to
die so you know because a long time ago
they showed this
I was trying to kill himself and he
tried to light himself on fire and like
his Suzuki Samurai it didn't work and
then he got out of the [ __ ] car he
had a [ __ ] 12-gauge shotgun he got on
his knees put it under his [ __ ] chin
and blew his [ __ ] head off on TV and
like kids were home from school it
happened like 3:30 in the afternoon so
like we can't do that [ __ ] anymore
right so what do we do we put on
periscope and God knows there's people
[ __ ] filming the [ __ ] and the dudes
up there so immediately by the way he
doesn't die I wouldn't be doing this if
the guy died he's [ __ ] up there right
and which i think is all a big sign
saying that Kevin Durant is going to
come to the Celtics
he's leaving Oklahoma alright he's had
enough of you wholesome racist people
out there he would like to perform in
front of some unwholesome racist people
in Boston that's what I feel
anyways so the guy's climbed up to KTLA
tower you're trying to get him down they
got a couple of [ __ ] air mattresses
or whatever the [ __ ] they put down there
and he climbs up and over the five and
it was amazing the guy was up there for
three [ __ ] hours and I got to tell
you I'd be lying to you if I didn't
start thinking about Survivor because it
really seemed like one of their
challenges where you always have to
stand on like a [ __ ] I don't know
like a bamboo pole with one foot you
know balancing a teacup on your head it
kind of seemed like that after a while I
kind of [ __ ] somebody stay up there
that long he's up there smoking
cigarettes and taking phone calls and
[ __ ] and all I could think was was if I
was going to kill myself I would never
jump off something you know what I mean
there's too much time to think about
what you just did on the way down right
it's just and it's just no way I even
know it's right the old right there Fred
it's just immediately [ __ ] over it's
just the [ __ ] mess you know it's like
come on man you know these it
somebody's got to clean that's that's
the last thing you do everybody said
that you're dead and then you leave a
giant [ __ ] mess somebody's got to
come over there with a [ __ ] wet vac
and try to clean up the goddamn scene
and God knows you know when you jump off
of something it's usually not your house
you know we really has a house big
enough to jump off of them die usually
land in the grass right so all you do is
just break your [ __ ] legs or some
[ __ ] and separate your [ __ ] show
that's saying you can't jump off a house
and die well I'm just saying you know
you want to make sure you die which
means you're going to go to someplace
that's a little higher up some sort of
public structure with concrete and
there's people walking by right they
just it's just such a selfish [ __ ]
way to do it right people coming up to
goddamn Street you know hey I'm so
excited to go see everybody wants some I
wasn't alive of the 80s but I'd like to
see Hollywood's version of it right it's
just like these last two weeks have just
been so wonderful in it it's all over
the [ __ ] place so anyway I just kill
and then the worst part is if you jump
and you actually [ __ ] live you know I
mean and then you feet appointed in
every [ __ ] direction except the way
they're supposed to you know and then
you got to go around being the
inspirational speaker you know with a
specially-designed [ __ ] wheelchair
you know somebody Reds feet you know
that point in every [ __ ] derail I
don't know some sort of Inc yet that
point could you said yes they will you
in like Hannibal Lecter
and then you got to be like standing
there you know with your custom speakers
talking to some [ __ ] group of people
about you know why you have so much to
learn what a [ __ ] way to find out
that you got so much to live for
it's never the [ __ ] answer you know
what I mean because it's bad think about
somebody depressed in st. Louis as bad
as that [ __ ] life is the st. Louis
Blues made the Western Conference
[ __ ] finals I mean yeah she killed
yourself you wouldn't see
that you know and then you can't go down
to the bar everybody's in a good mood
and all of a sudden some hot chick with
the st. Louis Blues t-shirt tied off at
the [ __ ] navel comes over gives you a
hug and I go wow that's what life's all
about getting a hug from a hot chick and
going home and rubbing one out to her ah
I can't believe I almost jumped off that
[ __ ] distillery you know what I'm
trying to say is no [ __ ] I can always
don't kill yourself
alright this is been a public service
announcement I'm gonna lie to you if I
didn't [ __ ] look up worse ways to
kill yourself
I found this [ __ ] website and the
unfortunate thing was the person tried
to be funny rather than just presenting
them they tried to put their own funny
spin on it like I'm about to write
alright seven most unusual ways to kill
yourself alright number one this guy
tried to kill himself by eating a Bible
the doctor said I was not strong enough
to pull the object out of the guy's
throat I don't believe that that's true
I don't believe somebody ate a Bible I
think that's one of those not the
creationists the other [ __ ] people
what's the other people there I don't
[ __ ] know if you don't believe in
creationism you really want a big bang
ISM person I don't [ __ ] know anyways
the next one guy killed himself in
prison by stuffing toilet paper down his
throat that's how bad prison is you know
I mean and you know if you ever saw a
Shawshank Redemption that seems like the
team's the better way to go and a more
pleasing thing to have in an orifice
sorry number five this guy in Singapore
worked at the zoo wanted to kill himself
natural way to do it why take a bunch of
sleeping pills and go peacefully when
you can walk into the tiger cage I bet
that's nice and quick too you know I've
always wanted a pet a tiger too so I
think you could get one quick petted
before he [ __ ] grabbed you by your
throat gave you a nice shake you just go
to so it's like getting put into the
sleeper hold by one of the UFC guys
except they would do it with their
mouths
um number four now this woman drank
Drano and let's discuss think that's not
a funny one be the one a guy decapitated
himself he got into an Austin Martin
tied a rope around his neck you know did
a burnout whoo that's it I guess he was
trying to get revenge on his wife I
don't know how that works you know to me
because was a lot of the cleaners today
I don't you could literally bleed out in
a car like that and they can get you
know never see that pimp my ride they
could take that Austin Martin down there
in a [ __ ] day they had all the
materials they could take that into your
put it back in and no one would ever
know that you ripped your [ __ ] head
off although I wonder what happened to
the car so they just kept going that's
another one now what if someone was
coming up the street doing this [ __ ]
paper route no one's as a paper anymore
it's an adult job all right
um it's one guy tried to kill himself he
had to shoot himself three [ __ ] times
that's not funny then another guy went
out into the woods he handcuffed himself
to a tree and then threw the [ __ ] key
away and then they could tell that he
struggled to try to free himself see
that's like you never do it nobody ever
[ __ ] killed themselves except for a
guy in jail we just like Emma might
spend the rest of my life fighting off
[ __ ] people trying to stab me or [ __ ]
me I mean that's when you got it that's
when gods like all right I get it I get
it
no worry die you don't got to explain it
come on in come on it you did your time
all right I can't end on suicide all
right let's go with the prediction here
all right tonight having watched zero
predators for San Jose Sharks games this
year having watched maybe three minutes
of that entire series I can tell you
without a shadow of a doubt I can't not
scene I know I'm trying to close my eyes
and see the winner that I believe that
the winner of tonight's game is going to
be I'm going to say
the Predators in the reason I'm saying
the president predators is because the
st. Louis Blues will be away team and
they want and her two home teams going
to lose a game seven on back-to-back
nights okay and that's the type of
philosophy right there
why Vegas always wins because there's
not an ounce of intelligence in what I
just said
all right I'm picking the Predators
that's it all right
Oh freckles it has to go to the has to
go to work and my gyms going to be
finished tomorrow starting Saturday Gold
Billy beefcake will be coming to us he
come to a town near you with my
overdeveloped freckled pecs right all of
that type of [ __ ] my sciatica is going
to be cured by then I just don't sit
down anymore you know then of course
that's going to lead to some sort of
feet problem but um anyways thank you
for listening as always and thank you
for all the great emails I got on Monday
I'm glad you guys enjoy when my wife
comes on a [ __ ] shits on me you know
I actually like it too it makes me laugh
I enjoy it
even though she's a pain in the ass
alright that's it so please enjoy the
music and we're going to give you
another half-hour of classic podcast
from from a year going by in a place I
can't remember
[Music]
me
hey what's going on it's bill birth it's
the Monday morning podcast that I am
doing on Tuesday at 11:20 in the morning
East Coast time
welcome believe that we're gonna be
slipping you know no excuse actually I
do have an excuse it was my girlfriend's
birthday yesterday so I was being a
great boyfriend paying attention to her
and someone had to suffer you know I
mean it's like a threesome someone
always feels left out matter how much
you try to pay attention my kid and I
met had threesome before I could have
had one once
I think twice the first time I didn't
realize that it was going down I was so
young and stupid I was actually sitting
there and I was thinking why won't her
roommate leave you know the [ __ ] and it
wasn't until like literally seven years
later I went oh wait a minute she wasn't
leaving cuz [ __ ] and then the other time
I was right there on the table and one
girl was absolutely gorgeous and the
other one I was not gorgeous let's put
it that way was so not gorgeous that she
eclipses the beauty of the other one you
know so so there you go yeah you learn
something about me right off the damn
fat okay Wow
one of this is what we're going to do
this week on the podcast you guys are
new to this [ __ ] new to my page I do
want to use every goddamn week and
people ask me questions and I try to
answer them and other than that I babble
I give you information about my life and
and that's it I'm [ __ ] out of it
alright I drank last night okay I was
celebrating connection went to this
goddamn restaurant in New York who went
to Bible and big fan of Mario Batali but
I like
but better baba was just - it was - what
he my palate was not sophisticated
enough but right I'll take the blame
Jesus Christ it was like regular dishes
with [ __ ] you'd never eat I had beef
cheek ravioli
yeah once you [ __ ] take that in for a
minute
all right and they had you know they had
like pheasants face [ __ ] lasagna you
know it was always like half what you
had heard of like goose liver [ __ ]
souffle so I don't know it was it was
good but Loula is the [ __ ] that's the
one that I like that's got like [ __ ]
you know regular animals body parts that
you eat mixed in with [ __ ] rigatoni
yeah what the [ __ ] you gonna do you know
yeah you try [ __ ] you know she wanted to
go there [ __ ] took it there and
that's what happened I ate two cupcakes
for breakfast what you think about that
it was sitting there leftover from the
party and I said that's a great way to
start my day let me give myself 9,000
calories of straight sugar it was unreal
it was like I did an eight ball
that's her eight the two cupcakes for 20
minutes I was just sitting there
thinking how [ __ ] great I wasn't I'm
like I'm [ __ ] awesome I could do
anything I want
I'm [ __ ] the greatest and 20 minutes
later when the sugar started wearing off
oh my god I started pulling the drapes
closed laying in here like I don't know
no no don't ever start your day with
[ __ ] - two cupcakes after he had a
beef cheek was [ __ ] ravioli
beefcake I was like cheek like the ask
you being cute they're like no they
actually know what I didn't have the
[ __ ] balls to ask him I didn't want
to know I was eating somebody's face
meeting a yak face yeah let me get the
yak paint rat rag goon
all right let's continue with the the
continuing story of American Airlines if
you listen to my my podcast last week
these cheap-ass [ __ ] and
American Airlines you know the alligator
arms the [ __ ] food at the first class
here I mean they had 20 people in first
class and they made 5 omelets and next
thing you know I was eating a bowl of
total over Nebraska actually no that's
not what happened
received the quick synopsis I said [ __ ]
you and you honeycomb cereal is his
first class I don't get a goddamn omelet
I don't want anything I said all of that
with a little less anger and no curses
so a few seconds later the guy came back
all of a sudden magically he has an
omelette and I'm like where did you get
that and he informs me that the pilot
said he already ate so I could have his
omelette and I was like I don't want his
[ __ ] omelette I want my omelette all
right I don't want to starving pilot you
know passing out up there seeing bogeys
we look forward on the goddamn yolk
whatever you call it all right so I sent
them a letter and this is the letter
that they sent back to me and I swear to
God you know back in the day if
something like this ever happened and
you actually wrote a letter uug the very
least they give you a free airline
ticket and I'm when I say back in the
day I mean like 2005-2006 now they don't
give a [ __ ] they just keep apologizing
profusely this is the dumb ass letter
they sent back to me I'm only going to
read you part of it because they just
keep saying the same thing over and over
again ok I'm gonna get the hiccups I
think I have sugar hiccups from starving
down to cupcakes
hang on a second miss room service hello
yeah I'm going to check out about like
15 minutes okay thank you
Jesus I didn't say anything she said
hello I said yeah I'm gonna check out 15
minutes at which point she could have
said okay
her old Olay you know but now she just
closes the door all right okay here's
the [ __ ] soda we got here this is
this is a letter that American Airlines
sent me okay dear mr. Berg thank you for
contacting American Airlines it's our
privilege to respond to your message
okay first of all right there they
already pissed me off okay don't don't
start with off with your [ __ ] stock
line like your Jackie Gleason you know
thank you for writing us in a way we go
you know a little shoving off the
Buffalo okay I'm very sorry to hear of
your disappointment with us and regret
that you did not receive your preferred
entree when you traveled with us in the
first-class cabin scale solace this is
because we want your travel experience
or improving premium cabins to be truly
something special we do our best to
cater our entree selections so that we
can serve each customer the entree they
prefer this is the part which is just
complete [ __ ] okay they want to make
sure that they serve the entree that I
prefer you know you can do that
bringing up [ __ ] eggs on the flight
this is what they write to do so we
determine which entrees are selected
most often it often and provision
accordingly it's an it's such [ __ ]
[ __ ] I mean and then they watch
Jurassic Park when Jeff Goldblum did his
little rant about chaos theory you think
as you take ten flights or a hundred
flights and you figure out you know
seven people want the omelet and in you
know nine people want something else if
such [ __ ] first of all nobody wants
the [ __ ] cereal
someone wants cereal at first class okay
you [ __ ] drop $1,500 or whatever the
hell is $850 on ticket you want
something a lot of substance
I'm sick of bitching about this all I
know is in the end of it I end up flying
[ __ ] a middle seat to [ __ ] Dallas
and all I got was a 150 dollar voucher
which will pay for 1/3 they didn't give
me anything mister peres we are not
unmindful of the inconvenience of you
well how the [ __ ] would you be on
mindful I wrote you a goddamn letter
it's hard as we are trying to deliver on
respecting your time by operating our
flights is scheduled it just wasn't
possible this time again we apologize
for the disruption of your travel plans
we're not giving you [ __ ] please fly
with us again soon we'll do our best to
get you to your destination as planned
really you're going to do your best
that's what you can give me American
Airlines well gee you know we're gonna
try that's a comforting attitude to have
when they're going to be flying a [ __ ]
at 36,000 feet off the goddamn ground oh
do I sound like a [ __ ] this week so
that's basically it that's that's the
the next level that they've taken it to
where it used to be like okay we [ __ ]
you over and the stewardess gives you a
[ __ ] you know that was 1975 then in
the 80s it was you know we'll give you a
free ticket and a skinny Michael J Fox
tie some of those things you know and
you had a little spiked up mullet and
that lasted for a good 20 years and
someone the last four or five years it
became we're going to [ __ ] you over red
bag go [ __ ] yourself what do you let
that go [ __ ] yourself it was 299 other
people on the plane it didn't fit in
complaint we're gonna do take the train
and take you nine days to get to New
York go [ __ ] yourself you know you're
coming back it's just eggs
get over yourself you know what to get
me over god damn barrel sons of [ __ ]
what am I gonna do flight 88 you know
Nina [ __ ] I don't know what in a
goddamn chicken I'm actually I think a
TA recently went out of business give a
flying airline and then you know you're
like yeah you know it's kind of weird
flight you know there was a crack in the
inner window actually that happened to
be on 88 one of the windows you know
they got like this big up the double
pane of glass they got the the one on
the outside the outside of the plane and
then they have the one on the inside the
extra level one and that one was cracked
and I believe there's a little bit of
water in there and I said to the to the
stewardess I was like woman there's a
[ __ ] crack in the goddamn window over
here I'm afraid I'm going to get sucked
out once we get above 6,000 feet she
sits like no carry still in her class
you know so I didn't feel bad when they
went out of business now I kind of felt
bad because now there's no there's no
other option I guess that's my another
option do I sit there and I take it on
American Airlines when they go go [ __ ]
yourself
all right we're going to give you a bran
muffin I hope you brought some water or
I fly another airline when their inner
window is cracked but no one picks it's
a concern candor winners crack well that
is that's why we got to open all right
this is this podcast is just across the
[ __ ] um let's get to some podcast
questions that I didn't even I didn't
have the time to [ __ ] look at this
week actually that's not true I want to
look at them and somebody I don't know
what's going on with my myspace page I
don't know if anybody else has had this
problem but I have not been able to
really add anybody for about a year you
know every couple of days they'll get
about 45 requests I'll accept them and a
day later I have 47 people taken off my
page and it's like really for all those
peoples spammers I don't know what's
going on so I'm having somebody look at
my account
the only question I can remember I can't
even remember it was something about
[ __ ] you know what movies do I find
scary well you know if you turn my
flight on American Airlines into a movie
I would have found that [ __ ] scary
what movies do I find scary anything
that involves a crazy woman I think the
scariest movies when I first got cable
in the early eighties when I had tight
chains and uh pony high tops that just
met the bottom of my jeans and no one
complained
because somehow you could get away with
that back time I remember the first
Friday the 13th when Jason came up out
of the lake that scared the [ __ ] out of
me
and there was another one hit here's one
for you okay I got a podcast question
for you guys
there was a movie I saw late night cable
and I can't remember what the [ __ ] it
was but it's somehow there was somebody
skating across the pond in slow motion
with impacts and I believe for some
reasons the the monster I'm picturing is
from that I know this isn't it but it's
a picture of my mind is uh what is that
monster book where the wild things are
remember what those monsters look like
in my memory that's what the monster
look like skating across the [ __ ]
lake and I know it isn't that but I know
somebody what are you one of my 14
listeners out there has to be a [ __ ]
horror for a film whatever the [ __ ] we
call someone who's really in the horror
films a geek yeah exactly a horror film
[ __ ] geek it was that one and it was
another one I was just thinking of and I
just sat up and I can't remember it I'm
getting a tax [ __ ] age
I literally just move my brain a little
bit the thought just went away wait a
second what the [ __ ] was I just thinking
let me lay back down let me see it'll
come back to me Gayle's talk in a bucket
we got to go back in time here I was
talking okay
the lake the wild things are see just
how my brain works worst linear once I
go past the moment I can't go back it's
like a [ __ ] traffic jam what the [ __ ]
was I trying to think of
ah [ __ ] I don't know oh I got it BAM
there we go
Dark Knight of the Scarecrow I like the
old horror movies okay this is what you
know I don't like about new horror
movies did they with that CGI [ __ ] they
can do so much insane stuff with
computers that they forgot how to build
suspense the old ones they use they used
to build it up they used to build up the
moment where the monster was going to
jump out at you because they had to
because it was just a guy in a rubber
[ __ ] suit you know what I mean but
now that they could they can you know
they can make it look like Godzilla's
stepping on New York they forgot how to
build suspense that's what I don't like
about [ __ ] horror movies now and
that's uh I think Japanese I don't know
everybody over in Asia seems to know how
to [ __ ] do that but nobody over here
does even like like like thrillers
whatever the [ __ ] it whatever a goddamn
thriller is might take that that movie a
perfect storm they had that goddamn big
wave
that's all they showed in the trailer so
everybody goes out to run out and see it
and then they don't develop any of the
goddamn characters to the point that I
don't give a [ __ ] about anybody in the
movie so by the by the end of the movie
I'm actually praying for the wave I
can't wait for them to kill George
Clooney and Mark Wahlberg and all those
other guys because I don't give a [ __ ]
about their characters because they
haven't done anything to make me give a
[ __ ] they just had a couple people speak
in Boston accent and you stick them on a
tugboat I'm supposed to give a [ __ ] if
they're going to die trying to get
lobster I'm just in a bad mood I'm in a
bad [ __ ] boat today all right you
know what it is it's a guy and don't
ever start your day with two [ __ ]
cupcakes it seems like such a great you
know such a great idea you know like oh
I'm eight years old this is what you
want to do but your parents never let
you you know and now I'm 39 and
fifty-one weeks
and finally the dream that I thought was
going to happen you know oh it could
happen and it doesn't play out like oh
my god how did I forget this [ __ ] I know
I forgot it because I have [ __ ] two
cupcakes with the sugar in my brain I
actually had a crazy week how crazy was
it bill um I flew into New York on
Wednesday I did Opie and Anthony thing
opening Anthony opening and Anthony show
Thursday morning then I did my show at
Caroline's in New York Thursday night I
got up Friday morning got on a plane
flew back to LA I did the guys Choice
Awards on Spike TV met all these famous
people they were all cool I had a great
time I met Nikki sick I was way more
thrilled and the after-party was at the
[ __ ] Playboy Mansion and I know what
you're thinking oh my god Playboy's
[ __ ] mention that must have been
unbelievable I quickly realized when I
got there there's two kinds of parties
at the Playboy Mansion there's B you're
famous and you can come by Wednesday
afternoon and actually meet the broads
that are in the magazine and then
there's the one that I want to wear it's
like yeah why don't you guys all just
stand on my in my backyard I literally
thought this jokes at the mansion right
it was going to be like me and eight
other people and just you know for
Playboy Bunnies eats just rubbing on my
chest hey there big boy I heard you're a
comedian now they just had they they had
the it was definitely the B team a
Playboy bunny
you know they had little bunny suits on
in the rabbit ear so let me tell you
something they were they were grade-a
hooter girls
and he could tell there was three of
them who were clearly being paid to
frolic in the pool and any girl with
bunny ears had like nine guys around her
was a [ __ ] sausage fest and this is
the funny thing nobody was hitting on
him they were standing there with their
[ __ ] cameras out taking pictures like
like they were at Disneyland and they
ran into Donald Duck or something
it was pathetic and you know Hugh Hefner
was roped off with his three [ __ ]
girlfriend 83 years old men's guide it
was vision that was the only thing I
wanted to do I just want to go in there
and shake his hand and then immediately
stick my hand in Bleach to get the
unbelievable smell of 50 years of [ __ ]
off of my hand and then fly back but he
was busy I understand he had to meet the
famous [ __ ] people so but still was
filled with [ __ ] and then I flew back
the next day six in the [ __ ] morning
I landed in New York at about 4:30 I got
my bag I went over Caroline's and I did
three [ __ ] shows you know and then I
went out drinking afterwards and that's
the kind of thing that leads you to be
in a country mood on a Tuesday morning
you know I did all of that and then I
ate two cupcakes all right so don't even
question my [ __ ] move all right so so
there you go that was my week little
party the Playboy Mansion I could stand
up on my first award show when is it
going to be yet you ask why I'll tell
you it's going to be on June 22nd and I
had a great time doing the set even
though most of the crowd was at a crowd
you know good-looking people hot chicks
texting each other
oh my god look at one this is going to
be over stick Ella I want to blow Jeremy
Piven gonna be on June 22nd and this
week coming up this week I'm going to be
at a good night's comedy club in Raleigh
North Carolina you can go to Bill Byrne
calm and get all the [ __ ]
informations and later on this month I'm
going to be the punchline in Atlanta
Hotlanta the brother to call it and I
think that date is June 19th or
something like that I don't [ __ ] know
I can't get on this hotel Internet and I
have to check out in 19 [ __ ] minutes
so I got to go apologize for the podcast
being a day late and forgive my country
myths on this podcast I'm going to blame
it on the sugar from the two cupcakes
whatever [ __ ]
half of sag huh starts the day with two
cupcakes so they call me Billy -
cupcakes Billy cupcake alright you guys
have a good week please keep the podcast
questions comments are about this week
man I don't know what's going on with my
[ __ ] page so please keep them coming
and let people know about my podcast and
thanks to everybody came on to my show
tonight in Philadelphia Chicago and in
New York City all right you guys all
have a good week I'll talk to you later
[Music]
what
and
[Music]
you